[Music]
thank you
welcome to another episode of what's up
Prof
hello Prof
[Laughter]
what's wrong with you I'm sorry
how are you I don't ask okay
so let's go on with this let's just
continue
the red heifers arrive
what's that all about Martin
the red heifers have arrived that's what
it's about well we have to pray that we
can understand what's going on here yes
our heavenly father thank you for
bringing us together again yes we need
your help more than ever we're on the
precipice of great events and we need
your guidance so Enlighten our minds
with the Holy Spirit and guide us
through this discussion in Jesus name
amen amen
Martin I know we've talked about these
topics before but there's always a new
development right
which places some urgency on the issue
of course you see everything even your
total Onslaught series
was what recorded 2004.
and everything is still relevant it's
just the players have changed a little
bit but their gender are still the same
the same agenda same thing happening
all right so the red heifers why are
they important and how relevant is it
for us
you know Martin the early church fathers
and all the reformers
realized or recognized that the Israel
of God
was not the physical descendants
but those that had the faith of Abraham
through all ages including the Christian
era
now we're not going to say what all the
church fathers believe but let's just
start with the reformers
Martin Luther writing on Galatians
chapter 6.
upon the Israel of God here Paul attacks
the false Apostles and the Jews who
boasted about their fathers their
election the law
Etc he's quoting Romans 9 45. it is
though he was saying the Israel of God
are not the physical descendants of
Abraham Isaac and Israel but those who
with Abraham the believer believe in the
promises of God now disclosed in Christ
whether they are Jews or gentiles
that is the position of protestantism
that is the position of Paul
and that is the position that was held
by the church fathers and also our
Pioneers that's it but some people have
forgotten this actually most most people
seem to have forgotten that
let's see what John Calvin had to say on
Galatians
upon the Israel of God this is an
indirect ridicule of the vain boasting
of the false apostles who wanted of
being the descendants of Abraham
according to the flesh
there are two classes who bear this name
a pretended Israel which appears to be
so in the sight of men and the Israel of
God circumcision was a disguise before
men
but regeneration is a truth before God
in a word he gives the appellation of
the Israel of God to Those whom he
formally denominated as the children of
Abraham by faith quoting Galatians 3 29.
and thus includes all believers whether
Jews or Gentiles who are united into one
Church
that is the reform position
it's reiterate that's the biblical
position why does the Evangelical World
reject it
could accept they swallowed the pull of
the Jesuits was it the Red Bull yeah
probably
well let's have a look at gratanginis he
was a church of England the theologian
he wrote romanism and the Reformation
and he writes about the temple of God
and he says observe the place occupied
by the man of sin the temple or House of
God this is not and cannot be any Jewish
temple that's rather emphatic isn't it
yeah and very straightforward
Paul who uses this expression in these
prophetic portrait of romanism
employs it both in Corinthians and
Ephesians with reference to the
Christian church
and The Second Epistle to the
Corinthians writing to Gentile
Christians he says ye are the Temple of
the Living God in Ephesians he calls the
church a holy Temple a habitation of God
through the spirit
to Paul emphatically the temple of God
was the Church of Christ
that's what they recognized right
this is the temple in which his
prophetic eyes saw the man of sin seated
it is not a person in the temple of
stone
but a power in the Christian church
is that straightforward that's
straightforward and very clear and it
also is exactly what the Bible says it's
very biblical
let's get the testimony of the spirit of
Prophecy
they all done the New Testament are
inseparable for both are the teachings
of Christ the doctrine of the Jews who
accept only the Old Testament is not
unto salvation
since they reject the Savior whose life
and Ministry was a fulfillment of the
law and the prophecies
and the doctrine of those who discard
the Old Testament
is not unto salvation because it rejects
that which is direct testimony of Christ
Skeptics begin with discounting upon the
Old Testament and detects but another
step to deny the validity of the new and
thus both are rejected
it's amazing how old is this yes and
it's still happening
it's an old trick why change your tune
if it works
that's what the devil says exactly he
doesn't come up with anything new
he just brings it up again because
people forget how it happened in the
past
all right now we've established that the
temple that the reformers believed in
was the church
and that the gospel is a whole you
cannot separate it into compartments you
cannot compartmentalize it
but yet they are going to build a new
Temple or that is their plan according
to gershom Shalom who is the Temple
Mount faithful have a Cornerstone ready
to lay
and he is Chairman of the Temple Mount
faithful Mount faithful the preeminent
organization in Israel working for the
rebuilding of the Third Temple
and the opined on record saying that in
Netanyahu government would be good news
for the prospect of rebuilding the
temple and now they have a very
conservative Netanyahu government
which must please them tremendous yes
and now it's actually he was gone he was
out
and then now he's back again yes he's
again prime minister so now everything
all the hype is going on it goes on
again now as we know the Temple Mount is
graced with the Dome of the Rock
and is that going to be a problem or is
that going to not be a problem well it
is a problem at this stage but with
everything happening I think it won't be
a problem anymore exactly it won't be a
problem anymore so is it in the way is
it not in the way is it standing in the
exact same spot or can we have something
similar to the buildings that they've
erected for the abrahamic house yeah
right that's what we can look forward to
now here is dispensation teaching
and it claims that Christians have an
interest in Jerusalem and Israel
now let's make it quite plain that uh
the Israel the modern Israel that we
have today is the Masonic construct yes
it is not a Biblical construct it is a
masonic construct which actually a
deception because
they take that Bible verse that says
that Israel will be gathered from
everywhere and every nation in the
tongue and they made it literal they
make it literal now whose plan is that
and why and what is the agenda we need
to understand what the Bible has to say
or else people will be misled yes then
everybody's eyes will be drawn towards
that all right so let's see what they
have to say these dispensationalists
Christians all around the world are
affected by events in Israel how
for one thing they are looking for signs
pointing to the second return of Jesus
Christ
perhaps one of the most significant
signs they look for is the
Reconstruction of the Holy Temple on
Mount Moriah the Third Temple
and the reinstituting of Old Testament
sacrifices this would be followed
prophetically by the appearance of the
man of sin the Antichrist in the temple
to shut it all down to call an end to
prayers and sacrifices this is called
the Abomination that makes desolate or
the abomination of desolation and then
they quote Daniel 9 27 Etc yes we just
had to make it clear that this is not
the true teaching oh that's that we're
reading here it's not we just read what
gratan Guinness had to say and he said
it's not the Temple of stone and the
Antichrist is not a man that's going to
come into a building made of stones is a
power sitting in the Christian church
and they had identified it as the Roman
papacy that's it and that was it
now this is entirely new theology so
again we have to reiterate where it
comes from
it comes from the pen of the Jesuits as
always everything apostate in this world
seems to come from that Source that's it
so dispensationalists believe as stated
by Louis Schafer
the dispensationalists believes that
throughout the ages God is pursuing two
distinct purposes
one related to the Earth with Earthly
people and Earthly objectives involved
while the other is related to heaven and
with Heavenly people and Heavenly
objectives involved
button so there are two plans which is
ridiculous because nowhere in the Bible
do you ever read of two plans
and when Christianity
rose up in the Jewish system
it was Jews three thousand of them that
were added to the Christian church when
the Holy Spirit was poured out at
Pentecost right
so it was a Jewish movement and for
three and a half years it stayed a
Jewish movement and then it expanded to
the Gentiles after the stoning of
Stephen
so the spiritual seed of Israel
was first
from the Lost Children of Israel and
then it went to the Gentiles it was born
out of that correct now ryrie states
that the church is not fulfilling in any
sense the promises of Israel the church
age is not seen in God's program for
Israel it is an intercalation
in other words a wedge put in
to time
so there was a Jewish issue now there's
a wedge called the Christian issue and
then we go back to the Jewish issue
which is absolute nonsense but this is
what people believe yeah and we have to
show why it is absolute nonsense because
this will be part of this end time
deception yes
another thing that they talk about if
you want to read what ryrie has to say
about it consistent literalism is the
heart of dispensational eschatology
so this would mean that we read the Old
Testament literally by itself without
the New Testament as its Expositor
which is ridiculous we just saw the
statement in the spirit of Prophecy that
you can't do that how many people want
to cut off the Old Testament from the
new many
Christ will have to Reign on a literal
Throne of David and the ancient Nations
such as Edom Moab and Ammon will have to
be resurrected to serve a literal Israel
which is again nonsense so where does
this come from Martin
well it comes out of the pin of the
Jesuits
and why did they have to invent such an
elaborate system to take the attention
of them yes because they had been
identified as the Antichrist and how
you're going to get an ecumenical
movement going if everybody knows that
you're the Antichrist nobody will want
to sit with you exactly so you have to
take the heat off
and the Protestant World swallowed the
LIE hook line and sinker
so futurism
Francisco Ribera a Jesuit of course he
was a Jesuit doctor of theology born in
Spain and began writing a lengthy
commentary in 1585
and this was an answer to the accusation
of protestantism
on the Book of Revelation Revelation
titled in
Sacramento's apostoli
Etc and published it in the year 1519.
then it was expanded upon by another
Jesuit Cardinal Robert bellamine one of
the best known Jesuit apologists
published a work between 1581 and
1593 entitled whatever
who cares what he titled it against the
Heretics of this time in which he also
denied the day equals your principle in
Prophecy and pushed the reign of
antichrist into a future period of three
and a half literal years
so there they were waiting for one
individual to come but he needed the
Temple of stone if you're going to be
literal
then you must be literal so the
spiritual Temple became a temple of
stone in order to have a temple of Stone
Mountain you must have a nation of
Israel yes in order to have a nation of
Israel you must create it because it
wasn't there because God said
it will be again your house is left for
your desolate so enter the Jesuits
controlling Freemasonry
and their Bank rolling system through
the Rothschilds and the Rockefellers and
they create the nation of Israel
and people are swept into this deception
now instead of looking at what the
Antichrist is doing in Rome while he
speaks from his little window all eyes
on Jerusalem waiting for a fictitious
individual to sometimes arrive precisely
what's happening absolute nonsense
because now the whole issue of the
Antichrist which was already raised by
Paul yeah and was already raised by John
and was already raised by Jesus in his
time
now becomes an issue for some future
time when the Christian church is not
even here anymore it's irrelevant to
Christianity through the Book of
Revelation away it doesn't make any
sense it's just meant for the Jews and
they'll have their second time second
chance and they will ruin over the
non-existent Etc
all right so obviously you must marry
the two religions again and this is
where liturgy comes in as we spoke last
time
so Jewish leaders meet Pope Francis to
commemorate the decree repudiating the
idea that the Jews killed Jesus
so they were exonerated by Pope Benedict
and he he lifted all blame from them
they had nothing to do with it after all
it was the Romans that crucified him but
what did he but at whose behest yeah and
what did he do about that part that the
Jews said his blood be on us no no no
that's all gone now because we need to
have an ecumenical soup and we'll start
with the abrahamic religions and the
abrahamic Accord
and we'll leave the Protestants to The
ecumenical movement and sort them out
there
so in this statement their statement the
rabbis also called upon the church to
join us in deepening our combat against
our generation's new barbarism
namely the radical offshoots of Islam
which endanger our Global society and
does not spare the very numerous
moderate Muslims
so now you have to have a common enemy
so that you can be friends
and the radical Islam is the enemy not
not Islam No just radical Islam
so radical Islam threatens world peace
in general and the Christian and Jewish
communities in particular the response
States we call on all people of Goodwill
to join forces to fight this evil
I know a greater evil than that Martin
that's it the rejection of Jesus Christ
is the greatest evil that has ever been
perpetrated and these people are experts
in it that's exactly they want to get
unity and peace and that's exactly what
we'll have to go
Jesus all right so the pope must
at least create the impression that he
and Judaism on the same page
and he must create the impression that
he and moderate Islam are on the same
page
and then we can happily reject Jesus and
have a religious system called the
abrahamic Accord
and live happily ever after in a
non-existent millennium of Peace yeah
all right so now having sorted out the
is issue with Israel and that they're
not responsible in any way for what
happened to Jesus
let's go to his overtures towards Islam
yes let's have a look
Pope Francis has arrived in the United
Arab Emirates it is the first time that
a pope has ever visited the
muslim-majority kingdom during his
two-day visit the pope is due to meet
leading Muslim clerics and Holt and open
air mass now this historic papal trip is
aimed at turning a page in Christian
Muslim relations in the region have a
look
the idea of the Pope visiting the
Arabian Peninsula the birthplace of
Islam was Unthinkable a few years ago
Pope Francis was invited by Abu dhabi's
rulers local Parish priestana says the
pontiff wants to Foster tolerance and
promote a moderate brand of Islam
well Martin
now that that had been achieved we need
to get some action on the Third Temple
now Donald Trump played a very important
part and we spoke about it a lot
and should he have a second term it
would be very interesting but if not
whoever follows in his footsteps will
pick up the gauntlet and run with it
right yeah
so activists lobbying for the
construction of a Jewish temple in
Jerusalem said Trump was playing a
similar role to the Persian Emperor
Cyrus the Great who allowed the Jews to
return to Israel from exile
and the Jews also praised Cyrus for
helping them build the second Jewish
temple in the same place where the first
had been destroyed
so if they all join forces they're going
to have a third Temple right which we
will see is actually a blasphemy that's
it we'll get to that
so they had breaking Israel news and
they showed Cyrus and Donald Trump
together
and it's interesting that they base
their conclusions on Deep Roots and
Bible codes and biblical numerology
that's spiritism that's that's kabbalism
that's got nothing to do with the Bible
maybe you can just explain a little bit
shortly what it entails well Bible codes
are are fascinating because they believe
that there are words and events hidden
in the Hebrew original document now you
must understand how this works because
the Hebrew doesn't have any vowels
and you can read it from left to right
you can read it from right to left you
can read it from top to bottom from
bottom to top or any diagonal
whatsoever you put that into a computer
and let's say you're looking for a name
like
Adolf Hitler
now there are many vowels in art of
Hitler so if you take the vowels out
then
that's Adolf right would be tough
and Hitler would be
that's it that's it now you must look if
you can find those in any computer
search on any diagonal what are the
probabilities that somewhere in the
Bible you will find
very very good
somewhere right and then you say ah I
found out of here yeah
and therefore the Bible has Adolf Hitler
written in code over here
and so you can continue and you can
decode the Bible
and use it as as a Ouija board basically
and you get what you actually wanted to
do but man does not live by bread alone
but by every word
that comes out of the mouth of the Lord
You're supposed to read what it says and
not look for stupid codes in it but in
any case that is what they do and
numerology is of course a totally
different thing again every letter also
has a numerical value and you can play
Forever how many numerical compilations
can you get
if you do the same kind of thing so this
is what happened when they use this
biblical numerology and Bible codes they
came up with
Trump being in a prophecy that he will
deliver and come up with anything you
want
it's like Nostradamus
exactly you can only understand
Nostradamus after the event
that's true because then it fits in
and so they even minted the half shekel
coin bearing his profile now that's an
interesting one because that's of course
what they had to pay for Redemption
money
they read they don't realize that they
missed their Redemption yeah that was
the temple yeah shekel
we're just recapping some of the things
that happened in the past to show where
we are now in the Stream of time so
let's just remind ourselves what he said
at that stage what Donald Trump said
yeah
I made clear that the problems of the
Middle East can only be solved when
people of all faiths come together
to fight Islamic extremism and pursue
Economic Opportunity for
people of all faiths and when you look
at what's happening you're seeing a lot
of progresses being made
that nobody thought could possibly be
made
and things are happening that I can't
talk about
but they're extremely positive I want to
thank the leaders of Israel and the UAE
for their courage and for their
leadership to forge this tremendous
agreement it will be known as the
Abraham Accord and I'd like to ask our
Ambassador David Friedman to please uh
explain why we're doing and calling it
The Abraham Accord David thank you Mr
President and congratulations to you on
the brokering this historic peace
agreement Abraham is uh many of you know
was the father of all three great faiths
he's referred to as Abraham in the
Christian faith Ibrahim and the Muslim
faith and avraham in the Jewish faith
and no person uh
better symbolizes the potential for
Unity among all these three great faiths
than Abraham and that's why this Accord
has been given that name
I wonder why that man on the left was
smiling when the Ambassador spoke I
wonder whether he realizes that there's
something terribly amiss over here yeah
probably you see there's not not
everybody will be blind but
unfortunately
this can is a deception that can lure
you in if you're not awake if you're not
awake
so you know when it comes to the Temple
Mount there are these pictures that show
that there can be Unity that the the
dumb of the rock can be then the temple
can be right next to it and maybe we can
have a Christian Enclave as well and
let's practice that in the meantime and
see if we can get a construct like that
so the Jews equate the Iman Mighty with
the Messiah a place of worship for all
people Muslims and Jews in discussion to
build Temple next to the dam of The Rock
and this could be what they are planning
and look how they are looking in
different directions and yet they are in
unity with each other
now now in the meantime Martin they've
built the abrahamic family house right
you remember actually in the right in
the beginning when we started the series
three years ago
episode where we
explained that this was on the horizon
that we're planning this yes now it's
done now it's done all right let's have
a look what they've done
[Music]
thank you
so Martin there they have built their
abrahamic house and you have three
religions
so the first one is called Saint Francis
Church which of course is a appointed to
Francis of Assisi and of course entails
climate change of course because that's
the issue and then of course the current
pope is Francis and he took his name
because of Francis offices correct
now the interesting thing is Catholicism
that is represented there in that
building
rejects the atonement and therefore is a
christless religion masquerading as a
religion of Christ because if you do not
accept that you are saved by the blood
of the lamb but by your works
then it's not a Christian religion it's
a Pagan religion
and then you have the Jewish yeah the
synagogue then you have the Jewish
synagogue and they reject Jesus Christ
as the Messiah and then you have Islam
that rejects Jesus Christ as the Messiah
so you have an Abraham Accord
without
Jesus Jesus okay well the other thing is
you've got the Catholic Church you got
the Muslims that are probably also
created by Roman Catholicism you get the
synagogue there with modern Israel also
coming from the Jesuits yes
and let's just make quite sure again
that the Messiah that we're talking
about is not Jesus so let's ask one of
the Sanhedrin members to clarify the
issue for us
[Music]
Christians want to hold it they can hold
it but we will never change our mind
we prefer to go back to Auschwitz and
not to change our religion this is the
main thing we are loyal what would
happen to Christians who refuse this
Messiah and hold on to Jesus
I don't know I'm not the Messiah
Martin he says he's a Jew and he's not
Jesus if the Christians want to believe
that that's their problem but he's not
Jesus and they will not accept it they
prefer to go back to Auschwitz
well I hope his wish doesn't come true
in a another form
because soon they will have to give an
account for their rejection of Jesus
Christ for the second time yeah for the
second time
it's quite clear that Jesus is not part
of the equation
and if the truth which is in Jesus is
not part of the equation then it's
outside of the truth
completely and you cannot have anything
to do with this no you cannot have
anything to do with this is a total
deception it's a it's a figment of a
jesuitical mind and it should be totally
rejected by anybody that has a Biblical
basis so let's just look at the biblical
basis
now in the Bible you have a very
prominent
teaching that that works on many many
levels and that's the issue of type and
anti-type
so let's go to the companion to the
Bible by barrows and ask them to give us
a definition of type and anti-type
well it says a type is a symbol
appointed by God to a dumb bread
something higher in the future
which is called the anti-type
now some people may wonder what does a
dumb right mean well I did for Susan all
right let's define it a dump right
means to represent in outline
or to foreshadow the future event
so a type is something that foreshadows
a future event
the best example that you can find is
the Lamb is the foreshadowing of the
anti-typical Lamb the lamb that taketh
away the sins of the world namely Jesus
Christ and the anti-type is always
greater in extent than the type the one
is a model in other words a
representation in outline and the other
one is the reality
that's a very important teaching
and once you start understanding it and
applying it then you can't go down the
slippery slope of literalism yes as
dispensationalists want to do because
then you destroy the whole anti-type
part correct so when it comes to the
temple and everything that was in it
everything was a type of a greater
reality
one greater than the temple is here said
Jesus yes all right so it was the
anti-type also of the Temple
and the Candlestick for example was a
type Jesus the light of the world that's
it so everything was a typology
and now they are taking a typology and
literalizing it
so the Ark of the Covenant for example
the Ark of the Covenant is exactly what
it says it's the Covenant but it has so
many types attached to it The Mercy Seat
which was on top for example
shielded you from the condemnation of
the Lord was pure gold that's
representing Jesus it was representing
Jesus who Shields you from the
condemnation of the law by taking the
condemnation upon himself
it's also the Throne of God it is the
seat of his authority
Angels long to look into it they look
down in awe and wonder onto the the ark
there's so much symbolism and typology
even in any of the constructs of the
Temple
and the rituals that were involved the
sacrificial rituals they pointed to the
greater reality the great sacrifice that
was to be made on man's behalf without
the shedding of blood there can be no
forgiveness of sins
and the ceremony of the red heifer was
very important because that was to
consecrate
of course the priesthood yeah
and the red heifer the red symbolizes
the blood of Christ and seeing that
Christ was pure there was to be no fault
in them just like in the lamb it had to
be without faults of the red heifers had
to be without fault for the consecration
because even the priests were a type of
Christ everything was a typology
so now here we have an interesting new
development from the 22nd of May
2023 CBN reports that the red heifer
ceremony
can probably take place in the near
future because they finally bred
pure red heifers and they have been
taken to Israel
for this event now this of course puts a
time frame on it that's it now all of a
sudden it starts giving a date correct
because the red heifers had to be three
years old that's also very interesting
you know Jesus's Ministry was three and
a half years old they have to be over
three years old and the typology is
immense
now once they start enacting this and
inaugurating a priesthood
that means that they reject the
priesthood of Christ
did it say that the Sanhedrin he said
that exactly so in other words it must
be based on a deception and here is a
man who is reporting on CBN News and
even he's confused
and make some very important points
correct let's listen let's listen to
what he has to say
nine Jewish priests plot a land on the
Mount of Olives and five red heifers all
these elements are in place for what
some Jews and Gentiles believe is the
key to building the third Jewish temple
some also believe it indicates the
coming of the Messiah the five red
heifers are now in a secure undisclosed
location in Israel plans include moving
them sometime soon to a visitor's center
in Silo where the Tabernacle of the Lord
once stood for nearly 400 years the Book
of Numbers explains that ashes of the
red heifer are used to purify priests
for their service in the temple to
replicate the ceremony mentioned in the
Bible they need to be at least three
years old and within their time span
they cannot have a blemish or anything
that would disqualify them for the
ceremony even one white or black hair
according to those working on the
project the ceremony of the red
heiferate needs to be performed on the
Mount of Olives and in a place that
would have looked directly into where
the temple stood the land I'm standing
on bought 12 years ago fits both of
those standards so we have the priests
we have the red effort we have the land
and we have everything ready we just
need to wait another one and a half year
Byron stands in a binay Israel a group
dedicated to building a Biblical Israel
works with Rabbi Mamo and helped find
the red heifers in the U.S he says these
would be the first in two thousand years
and that the process toward a third
Jewish temple began when the Jewish
people started their return to the
promised land from the four corners of
the world culminating with Israel
becoming a nation Stinson says they plan
to invite everyone to the red heifer
ceremony that may take place in Passover
2024. certainly a lot of interpretations
on this but we need to keep in mind the
words of the Prophet Jeremiah that the
Ark of the Covenant won't even be
remembered anymore so how can you have a
third temple with out that Ark of the
Covenant there wasn't one in the second
temple and in herod's Temple but do we
need that Ark in in order to really
establish that Temple and then do we
have the words of Stephen as he was
being stoned that God does not dwell in
temples made from hands he dwells in you
and me are we the Third Temple well
obviously people are of different Minds
about this does a temple need to be on
the Temple mount in order for the
Messiah to come is the Messiah going to
construct that Temple if so what are
these sacrifices uh is the sacrifice of
Jesus enough for all for all eternity as
a Christian I believe that
Martin the second temple
didn't have the Ark of the Covenant
because it had been hidden away yeah
but Jesus was the embodiment of the law
that's it so he was in that second
temple
and therefore the anti-typical Arc was
actually in the temple complete with
mercy seat and everything
so it was there but the third one yeah
could it have it no no no so it was in
the first temple as a type
it was in the second temple as an
anti-type
but the Third Temple it's totally
lacking exactly
so it and if Jesus is not there
either through the
Arc of the Covenant or literally
it's like Jesus said it was is desolate
it's desolate totally desolate
all right but let's look at look at this
from a Biblical perspective
what was the purpose of Israel in the
first place Isaiah 49 verse 6.
and he said it is a light thing that
thou should be my servant to raise up
the tribes of Jacob to restore the
preserved of Israel
I will also give ye for the light to the
Gentiles that there mayest be my
salvation unto the ends of the Earth
did they fulfill that commission no
unfortunately not no they ensconced
themselves and said salvation was for
them alone the rest would be driven into
the sea yeah there's a few Nations that
have similar viewpoints in that yes
all right John 3 18 He that believeth on
him is not condemned but he that
believeth not is condemned already
because he has not believed in the name
of the only begotten son of God
didn't I just admit that they don't
believe so aren't they condemned as a
nation not as individuals no
anybody has access to the kingdom of God
but the only way to get into the kingdom
is through Jesus
they've rejected him they've rejected
him the first time they're still
rejecting him so in other words their
whole Temple
construction that they are planning and
all the red heifers and everything that
they require for that
is a deception yeah
Matthew 23 37 oh Jerusalem Jerusalem
thou that killeth the prophets and stone
of them which are sent unto thee how
often would I have gathered thy children
together even as the hen gathereth the
chickens under her wings and ye would
not
have they changed no no
behold your house is left unto you
desolate Matthew 23 38 what does that
mean that means it won't be occupied
again it's done it's done it's over
is there any point in building a third
Temple no it's a deception like you said
all right let's have a look at Luke what
he has to say about that same issue
behold your house is left unto you
desolate
and verily I say unto you you shall not
see me until the time come when you
shall say blessed is he that cometh in
the name of the Lord in other words not
until the second coming
not not someone walking on Earth and
going to build this Temple or sit in it
no and as he said they're not waiting
for Jesus they're waiting for someone
else but certainly not Jesus
well Jesus predicted the destruction of
Jerusalem in Matthew 24 and Jesus went
out and departed from the temple and his
disciples came to him for to show him
the buildings of the Temple
and Jesus said unto them see ye not all
these things verily I say unto you there
shall not be left here one stone upon
another that shall not be thrown down is
that emphatic very much so
now let's ask the question why
and let's answer the question Through
the Bible Luke 19 44.
and I shall lay thee even with the
ground and thy children within thee and
they shall not live in thee one stone
upon another why
because the newest not the time of thy
visitation
okay why
because thou knew it's not the time of
thy visitation what visitation when
Jesus came to this earth exactly they
knew it not that ejected him they
rejected it they passed it by and that
is why the house is desolate and as long
as they reject him and keep him up the
house is desolate that's it
all right what is the house
let's first continue with Mark
one verse 15 saying the time is
fulfilled and the kingdom of God is at
hand repent ye and believe the gospel
so instead of a temple of stone the time
was at hand for the kingdom of God to be
set up
the kingdom of God when did it start it
started right then in the beginning the
time is at end and ever since then
they are pressing in according to Luke
16 the law and the prophets were until
John that's John the Baptist right now
since that time the kingdom of God is
preached and every man presses into it
not to be confused that we don't have to
adhere to the law and the prophets
anymore because it was until John no but
they prophesied that it would come and
now it had come because the Messiah had
come and actually he came to establish
that the law and Prophets stand and the
kingdom which is based on the law and
the prophets
and everybody presses in so since that
time anybody who wants to be part of the
Kingdom has to enter through the right
channels
and if you want to know what the right
channels is then go and watch Pilgrim's
Progress then you will understand that
you need a document to enter which is
the righteousness of Christ that's it
that Mercy Seat
Mark 9 1 and he said unto them verily I
say unto you that there be some of them
that stand here which shall not taste of
death till they have seen the kingdom of
God come with power so he gave a
demonstration on the Mount of
transfiguration that this was the time
when the law and the prophets Moses and
Elijah by his side would culminate in
the Kingdom yeah so just to put it more
plain because a lot of people use this
verse to say there's a contradiction in
the Bible because this pointed that
people will be alive then that will see
Jesus come they saw the kingdom they saw
the power and the glory that surrounded
Christ where he was the king of this
Kingdom on that mountain of
transfiguration correct
second Corinthians 6 16. and what
agreement has the temple of God with
idols for ye are the Temple of the
Living God as God it says I will dwell
in them and walk in them and I will be
their God and they shall be my people so
type had made anti-tire
the temple stood for God's people
they were to be associated with the
temple but inside the temple in the
second temple you had Jesus Christ who
was the embodiment of the law
and this is the religion that you have
to accept
and there they were
and they were the temple and ye are the
temple yes and that is it has to bring
about a change in your heart correct
like you mentioned in the previous one
people like to do the physical so that
when they finish they can say oh okay
I've done it now I've gone to church it
must be a change must be a change I must
start with repentance right
let's go to Ephesians
and are built upon the foundation of the
Apostles and the prophets Jesus Christ
himself being the chief Cornerstone so
now we're not talking about stones
we're talking about people yeah yeah one
of them being Jesus Christ
in whom all the building fitly framed
together groweth into a holy Temple in
the Lord in whom ye also are builded
together for habitation of God through
the spirit so where's the Third Temple
Martin yeah it's the church
it's the church and it's made up of
people it's made up of people
Revelation 3 12
him that overcometh will I make a pillar
in the temple of my God
so there's some overcoming to do right
and he shall go no more out
and I will write upon him the name of my
God and the name of the city of my God
so even equates the temple with the city
and the name the character of God is
written into their hearts in other words
I will put my law into their hearts
and that's the New Jerusalem which comes
down out of Heaven from God and I will
write upon him my new name
so typus made anti-type you cannot
revert back to a type that is a
blasphemy yeah
let's make sure one Peter 2 5 ye also
are Lively Stones Living Stones
and I built up a spiritual house a holy
priesthood to offer up spiritual
sacrifices acceptable to God by Jesus
Christ so if you're supposed to bring
spiritual act sacrifices does that
negate the literal sacrifices yes it
does yes you it like you just said it's
a slap in the face if you go back to the
literal correct because you are saying
anti-type has not met type yeah do you
when Jesus came the first time it he
wasn't worthy that's actually what this
is saying basically what it says
so Romans 2 verse 28 for is not a Jew
which is one outwardly neither is that
circumcision which is outward in the
flesh but he is a Jew which is one
inwardly and circumcision is that of the
heart and the spirit and not the letter
whose praise is not of men but of God so
God wants you to understand what the
temple stood for and you must be changed
into that image
that's what it's all about
Galatians 3 29 and if you be Christ then
you are Abraham's seed and heirs
according to the promise
so there is no literal seed it doesn't
exist it's a figment of the imagination
to take away the tension from everything
else and from the change of heart that
you have to undergo
Galatians 6 15 for in Christ Jesus
neither circumcision availeth anything
nor uncircumcision but a new creature
and as many as walk according to this
rule peace Beyond them and mercy upon
the Israel of God that's the Israel of
God yeah not a Freemason construct that
has been established somewhere in the
Middle East
Hebrews 13 verse 14 says for here we
have no continuance City but we seek one
to come
and Hebrews 11 10 says for he looked for
a city which has foundations whose
Builder and maker is God
and he's the Cornerstone that's it so
without him this a new Temple will be
futile so where's the Cornerstone in
this abrahamic house well it's not Jesus
Christ no probably the the Antichrist
the Antichrist is bringing this because
it's a false system absolutely false
system so let's ask the question again
does God have two Brides
Isaiah 2 19 and I will betroth thee unto
me forever yeah I will betroth thee unto
me in righteousness and in judgment and
in loving kindness and in mercies he's
talking to his people throughout the
ages
I am jealous of you says Corinthians
with Godly jealousy for us have have
espoused you to one husband that I may
present you as a chaste virgin to Christ
he doesn't have two Brides it cannot be
they cannot be this one and the other
one will be raptured and this will the
Christians will sit in heaven and then
the Jews will be on earth false religion
that the scripture have concluded all
unto sin that the Promise by faith of
Jesus Christ might be given to them that
believe if if Christ is not part of the
equation
there's no promise nothing
or second Corinthians 1 20 for all the
promises of God in him are yea and amen
unto the glory of God by us you leave
him out none of the promises apply
Galatians 4 7 wherefore Thou Art no more
servant but a son and if a son then an
heir of God through Christ if you want
to be an heir of the Kingdom
you better be in Christ
there's no other way there's no other
way
so the Divine Glory has left the temple
behold your house is desolate so the
church is now the living Temple no
you're not that you are the temple of
God and that the spirit of God dwelleth
in you isn't that very clear and it's
beautiful because now
in a little Temple
God is not there even that commentator
recognizes it and wondered what what are
they doing so where is he now he's in
here
let's read this quote in spiritual gifts
the blood of Christ and of his disciples
whom they had put to death was upon them
an in terrible judgment they were
visited the curse of God followed them
and they were a byword and a derision to
the Heathen and to Christians they were
shunned degraded detested
as though the brand of Cain was upon
them yet I saw that God marvelously
preserved this people
and had scattered them over the world
that they might be looked upon as
especially visited by the curse from God
that's rather hard yeah it means that
they are there for an example an example
I saw that God has forsaken the Jews as
a nation
yet there was a portion of them who
would be unable to tear away the veil
from their hearts some will yet see that
prophecy has been fulfilled concerning
them
and they will receive Jesus as the
savior of the world and see the great
sin of their nation in rejecting Jesus
and crucifying him
individuals amongst the Jews will be
converted but as a nation
they are forever forsaken of God
and that's very hard what does that mean
in terms of the nation that now exists
it's not a nation under God no it's a
nation under another Power
now that that just puts it in harmony
with the rest of the world because the
whole world is under that other power
but there is a kingdom yeah and you
can't be part of it you can press in you
can
but there is this particular door that
you have to pass that's it there's a
requirement and that is
if you put away Jesus in anything
to be an ecumenical movement or have
peace and safety anything like this
you will be your left house will be left
to your desolate all right so Martin
let's just sum this up
the red heifers have arrived there are
five of them
one of them will probably qualify they
only need one
they want to inaugurate the priesthood
they say it will have to happen probably
in 2024.
when they actually do that that's the
first step to starting the temple
and to fulfill a false prophecy which
has been erected on jesuitical terms
now I'm only interested in the time
frame yes all the animals are there
2024 is when they can start doing it
they don't want to wait too long
because what if they develop a gray hair
then they can't use them right yeah
so are we in the Stream of time
coming closer to the events of the final
rejection
again of Jesus Christ yes and
unfortunately it's coupled with
deception so for a lot of people it
would look like it's the right thing
it'll look like the right thing but it
is the final
lust through the rejection publicly of
Jesus Christ as the savior of the world
so may God give us wisdom
study your Bibles realize who the temple
is
and look at the look at the playing
field look at what's happening
look at it as if it were a movie
but remember
that the events that are taking place
there
showed the
urgency that is required
to make some changes over here let's
pray
Heavenly Father
the world is living in a lie everything
around us is a lie
and we've spoken about that before
but there is truth to be found amidst
the LIE you are the way the truth and
the life and nobody comes to the father
except by you
thy law is truth Thy word is truth
help us to cling to truth
that we may not be swept away by the LIE
is my prayer in Jesus name amen
[Music]
thank you